hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and I just want to tell you about
this Market software research tool that
you might be interested in you know
everyone always talks about finding high
percentage trades you know the trades
with the 4:1 reward to risk ratio and so
on and then just leave you to it what
the software does is it finds you high
percentage trades and shows you their
success rate in the past the average
profit per trade and much more so at a
click of a button you will know what
Futures Contract stock or Forex pair to
buy or sell when to buy or sell the
trade's winning percentage and average
profit and a few other things so watch
this video and you'll learn more about
the software and if you stick around to
the end you can see how you could save
about about a hundred bucks off the
software even so again it's not very
expensive but it's really I think a very
useful tool I said it's very rare that I
promote another trading software product
but I have to be honest to tell you that
this software can really open your eyes
to some amazing trading opportunities I
even own the software so I mean that
that's how much I believe in it so
let's get started it's called trade
minor and you know they have three
modules they have a stock module a
Futures module and a Forex module um but
before I get started really quick you
always got to go through these
disclaimers this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or making any other type of
investment decision Futures Trading
contains substantial risk and it's not
for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's fin Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
basically don't trade with money you
can't afford to lose I mean that should
be common sense but still um not
everybody heeds it so this software you
know again it's called trade Miner and
you know the reason why I believe they
called it minor is because you're really
data mining um past history of of the
futures or the Forex pair or the stocks
and it's really easy to use so you know
you can see here on my desktop I've got
you know the the Forex version here the
Futures version here the stock version
here and all you do is you just click on
it and you know it pops right up very
very fast to load boom yeah that's it
that's how fast it loads and to use it
it's very simple um you know you just
start here you know step one there's
step two there's trade alert settings
there's a lot you could do with the
software but I'm just going to show you
the real basic stuff the research part
of it on how to use
it so how you want what you want to do
to find you know trades is you go to the
month that you want to look at so you
know we look you know right now is today
is uh February 11th U well I don't know
let's start here in February and you
know there's a few parameters you can
play around with you know find trends
that have won at least 90% of the time
showing both you know bullish and
bearish list trends that have at least
five trading days you know or but not
more than a certain amount I leave it
blank cuz I want to see all and you know
mine at least 10 years of history and
you just click dig now okay I mean
there's a few other things here but
again I mean you could figure that out
when you get the
software and you can see it's running
through its calculation right now it's
you know going through the database of
of data mining the data and looking for
these profitable trades
so you can see the results 2011 and you
know there's a score it tells you the
trend the symbol the instrument starting
on and on you know when you should get
into the trade when you should get out
the win percentage number of years
calendar days the trade last average
profit return on money average profit
you know for the the trade average
profit in tix risk reward average daily
profit Max
gain so on and so on you know the margin
per contract and you know there's what
they have the score it's a weighted
score I'm not going to get into what it
is but you know the higher the the
number then you know the technically the
stronger the trade I have it filtered by
score here so it has the highest score
on top so let's just take a look okay so
the first one is bullish V oil get long
on February 1st get out on the 13th the
13th is just Monday I said today
Saturday I'm recording
this and you know let's see how it
looked okay so it's get Long March bean
oil Z here it
is February
1st see EXP and this up a little
bit where is February here we go
February 1st that's 31st here's February
1 so you could see it's giving you you
know assuming you'll be getting in Long
somewhere near the
open you know that's
3365 and we're to close on Friday
34 65 so
you know that's a nice move you know
that's a profitable trade right
there and you know you go down you could
see there's different contracts bullish
bearish you know different contract
months you know there's there's really a
lot there's 20 2011 here um you know
let's go back look at January you know
January just ended let's see if some of
these trades were profitable or
not again this is how fast it it works
you know it's doing the calculations
right now as I'm
talking to
you okay so it's done so let's see the
top one
bearish crude oil okay get short on this
bear so you're getting short on January
4th cover it back on the
25th
okay was crude oil that was May
crude what is it get short on the fourth
where am I here
that's not it so the fourth is where oh
that's the third it's too bad didn't
tell you to get short on the third but
anyway this is the fourth you know this
is the open
53 26 you know we trade up actually went
against you all the way to
5502 but let's see where closed on the
uh 25th so again you're looking here
5333 roughly 5328 we'll call it then on
the 25th this is where your cut in it
back you know 5290 so you know was a
small winner and this is just the raw
data right you mean don't take these
trades strictly off get long on this day
get out on that day um you know try and
you know work with the the fundamentals
that's going on in the Market at the
time you know there's other ones
here yeah I probably stay away from
things like the dollar Index or you know
any cross rate that involves the dollar
I can't say cross rate involves the
dollar but you know any Market that
involves you know the US dollar in it in
the sense of you know being a a foreign
exchange product and I I say that
because you know there is a Forex model
I'll show you the Forex model here
module rather but the reason I say that
is because with Donald Trump you know
being the president there's a lot of
uncertainty in the global financial
markets and it's going to effect have a
direct effect on the dollar so maybe
some of these Trends I mean you may get
some monster Trends in the currency
markets but you know I don't want to
take that risk because you know
something is said or misinterpreted that
comes out of the president's mouth it
can have an effect on the
market so you know just look at some of
these other ones here gold here you I
know gold was up in in January and you
this is bullish it's got a score of 1.56
Buy on January 3rd she hold it on the
way until May so this trade should last
about uh two months you know 58 days I
know this one's in the money I know gold
is up for the Year let me just take a
look this April
gold buy it on the 3 of January where's
Jan here's 2007 so there's January 3rd
first trading day of the year where we
trading you know around
1154 where are we now you know 12 1235
so 11:54 up to
12:35 in the gold
yeah and that trade still ongoing um
yeah I don't know let's take a look I
honestly I
haven't
um nikai I don't know if I got Niki in
my
charts again I'm just sort of picking at
some of these I some I'm sure some work
some don't
work I don't know which nikai they're
using for this um whoops
I assume CME but again you know you have
CME you have sgx it could be either one
I don't know it's
bearish what did it say here bearish
you're selling it on the 4th covering it
back on the 11th let's see I don't know
I I don't know I don't remember off top
of my head what the nikai did there well
first we'll start with sgx the simx one
the third here's the third so you're
selling it on the 3D
19210 this a small because I know the 3D
of January I believe is is a trading
holiday in
Japan and covering it back on the 11th
well the
11th
was January 11 11 was a
Wednesday so here so you know this one
didn't work out how it look on the CME
CM e is not going to be much different
dollar well it's denominated it's about
the same you know buy it here whoops
this is the 11th here or the 3rd rather
January 3rd it's bearish and this is the
11th so you know it's you know that one
didn't work out you know it went up
against you was telling you to get short
so you know not every trade is going to
be working out I mean you should have
stops as well let's uh take a look at so
that's the Futures
module you know me personally how I
would trade it I personally I would look
at the the trades with the longer
duration longer calendar days now here's
a nice one well this one's got a score
of zero but you know it's mini da okay
well yeah you know where DA's been
doing that's telling you to get long at
the end of uh
January I mean if you support Trump
you'd be getting long but uh let's see
where's gen 31 so this is January
31 you it was actually a big down day
that day but you know say you got short
here where are we now you know you're
getting short at uh just below 19900
we're trading above
20 you know 2200 so it's already 300
points uh in the money honestly
something like that you know these
longer term trades i' I'd be looking at
um you know options you can trade
options on those you know I can buy some
outof the money
calls if if I'm expecting the money the
market to go up or you know do the uh
puts on the way if I'm expecting them
the market to come down let's take a
look at the the Forex version um again
it was very similar it just says Forex
up here in different color and you know
where are we February here okay this
one's set between one you know up to 6
days you 6 days is not very long let's
see if it looks any different here with
with this
um okay so where are we right now today
is the
uh February
11 okay well these are just you know
trades let's take a look at January it's
probably better I could give you some
examples of what happened
um okay so what do we got here let's
take a look you know the first one Euro
versus New Zealand dollar short on the
15th cover it
back on the
26 uh Euro New Zealand EU
R so I don't have these there so you
know again I'm
just some of these are new we'll take a
look at a couple of these uh Aussie
dollar Swiss frank
aie
swissy
and Euro versus
Canada again me personally I would just
you know the fourth one is New Zealand
versus US dollar then here you got US
versus Canada I would just stay away
from those uh US dollar pairs for now um
I said you know who knows what's going
to come out with uh out of the White
House
or anywhere and it's going to have a
profound effect on the uh exchange rate
with the US dollar I think some of these
might be a little bit more stable so
we'll start here Euro versus uh New
Zealand
bullish on the 15th okay where are we
here 15 was it's a Sunday so it'll be
the
16th where are we trading here around
1499 until
when until the
26th so from you know from this one down
to 26 so this one you know this one
didn't work out okay now one of the
things you can see also with this is it
shows you the last SE the last 10 years
down here what sort of profits there
were on these trades to be
had Aussie versus
swissy you again you can't I don't you
know I I wouldn't trade it where I'm
just taking every single trade and you
know just blindly taking it because it
says buy it on this day and sell it on
that day no I mean you should you know
when you're trading sort of you know
when you're trading something like this
you know try and wrap it around with
your what you're thinking the market is
doing you know if you have a view
because you know maybe across a moving
average I hate to say across the moving
average but you know a lot of people
trade um Forex with with averages
unfortunately but um I mean you know use
it with the way you're trading you know
if if you're a bit of a longer term
Trader uh let's see here so this one is
Aussie versus
Swiss and it's bearish on the
15th uh of January where's Jan
15 again
here until the 25th so that's what
75 uh up around 7562 until the what day
25 24 25 so this one was about Break
Even um it went up it went
down you know so it had a very small uh
return although you could see you it did
have this one big one this one out sized
one here but honestly the rest of these
you know they're all kind of
small Euro versus Canada okay this one's
kind of mixed you see last couple years
kind of small had some nice big years in
there had this big loser there but uh
let's take a look at how it
worked Euro versus
Canada okay so you're getting was
bullish on the 10th of January where is
the 10th of January
okay so this is 10th of January right
here right you see uh 101 2017 down
there on the
bottom so that's uh
139 call it here
13971 72 73 somewhere in here you know
okay we'll call say you got long here at
140 the
figure uh actually the 10th and you hold
it it until the
19th where's the 19 oh that's 18 here's
19 I don't know if you're going to be
getting out on the you know near the
open or near the close I'd imagine you'd
either be getting out somewhere I don't
know um you know I'd imagine be getting
in near the opens and Out near the
closes of the day you know that just
makes sense you know you're holding it
otherwise it would say the previous day
would say the 18th um but so you know
this is a nice move we'll call it 140
even if you got out here 141 now that's
a it's 100 Pips up here even it's
another 100 Pips so at least 100 Pips
out of this trade so you know as you can
see there was you know one winner one
sort of break even one loser um you know
just on these these three again I'm not
going to go through all of them um you
know just get the
software and you know and play around
with it I think it will
definitely definitely help your
trading and you know what do you got to
do
and just basically go you know on this
web page scroll down to the
bottom where I have
this click here to get trade Miner and
what you do is you click on there it
takes you to this page this is what it
looks like scroll down to the bottom and
they have the special deal you could get
the stocks the Futures the Forex I
showed you the Futures and the Forex
modules they have a stocks one um I'm
not a big stock Trader but you know if
you get these two otherwise you can get
a single market and it's
$97 so basically as long as you buy you
know the Futures you know if you trade
Futures in stocks then you get the Forex
for free if you trade Forex and stocks
basically you get two of them and they
give you one extra for free which is is
worth it and you know it includes you
know the historical data Going Back 40
years each
year you know they got new data that
comes out
obviously and you want to get the
refreshed database you know after year
cost you that and you know you get the a
lot of other stuff you could do with the
software actually but um again I just
showed you you know the basic
fundamentals of of how to use it
honestly it's there's a lot to it and
again you know for that price of you
know
$194
it's not expensive you know as far as
research tools go especially for the for
trading um you know I'm sure I know I've
spent a lot of money on software that
was just pure crap I sell software
and you know again $194 is is considered
very cheap already and actually what you
get for it it's got you know it's great
value you know it's got a 30-day money
back guarantee you can see right here as
well so again I don't think you go wrong
with the software you know even if you
just get you know a couple you know say
you just take the top five trades a
month you know out of the 200 that you
just saw like in in the Futures you know
you just take five of them and you know
if two of them are are winners but you
know Big
Winners you know and maybe one's a
scratch the other two are losers and you
know then it's worth it you know I said
it might be worth it you you trade some
of these longer term tra um trades you
know for that last for months you know
maybe buy some out- of- the money
options and you know just you know sit
on them you can buy them for really
cheap I might I might do that actually
I've been thinking about it is you I've
been talking to someone that trades
options and you know he's trying to get
you know he's trying to win me over I've
never been a big options guy for me
you know options is basic at this stage
in my life is just basically buy calls
and buy puts I don't get any anything
more fancier than that maybe you know
some straddles or or some things but
again um you know that those days are
past
me and you know so there's definitely
ways you could use this in your trading
you know there there's other things that
they offer but you know at this this
version this $194 version for the the
three modules is money well spent I mean
again and you you you won't
go you won't you know look back and say
oh this is a waste of money you know
some people might actually you know but
you know for those that you know want a
starting point on you know some
profitable trades opportunities this is
a good starting point so you know thanks
and you know hope hopefully you'll
you'll find some value in this software
and you could use it in your trading so
thanks for watching this and bye-bye